so the next question elder skeet as you alluded
to it before is what takes place in the millennium
all right during the millennium satan and his
evil angels they are confined to the earth
in ii peter chapter 2 verse 4 the bible says
for if god spared not the angels that sinned
but cast them down to hell and deliver them into
chains of darkness to be reserved unto judgment
so the chains represents the circumstances
in which they find themselves and as i said
during that thousand year period they will be
restricted to the earth with no want attempt
no trouble to cause among humanity as we said
the wicked there are in the graves the righteous
living and righteous there resurrected taken to
heaven now what will they be doing in heaven we
go to first corinthians six read verses one and
two we'll also go back to revelation 20 by the way
first corinthians 6 1 and three paul is
rebuking the corinthians pursuing one another
in the secular courts which by the way we should
not do advantages should not sue one another let
me say that again adventists should not take one
another the court we should let the church handle
it and it is better to suffer a loss than to have
church members fighting each other in a public
courtroom paul is condemning this and he says
in verse 1 let me pray again father in heaven as
we continue this session give me wisdom and give
comprehension to your people in jesus name i pray
amen dare any of you having a matter against
another go to law before the unjust and not before
the saints paul is saying how could you go to
some unsaved person to settle a matter between
two saved people he tells them don't do that do
we not know that the saints shall judge the world
that's what he's saying the question then
becomes when will the saints judge the world
it is during this thousand-year period that
the saints will judge the world verse 3 says
know ye not that we shall judge angels which
angels the fallen angels this is what will
take place during the thousand years now if we
go back to revelation 20. we read from verse 4
and i saw thrones and they sat upon them and
judgment was given to them and i saw the souls
of them which would be headed for the witness of
jesus and for the word of god a wish had which had
not received his worship the beast or his image
or received his mark upon their foreheads in their
hands and they lived and reigned with christ a
thousand years and so part of the activity will be
reigning with christ being involved in
the administration of the entire universe
but also based on corinth first corinthians 6 1-3
examining the judgment that is to be poured out
upon the wicked you see even though god is just
he allows human beings to examine his justice
before he sent the flood he talked with
noah before he destroyed sodom and gomorrah
he talked with abraham and before he destroys
this earth in some way he discusses it with
jesus who represents the earth because he was
human and so god in his mercy not needing human
support he allows humanity to examine the steps
he has taken so that they can be satisfied that
god is a just god and so for a thousand years
we shall be examining the lie not as i said we
i hope somebody said amen we shall be in the lives
of those who are lost so that we can be satisfied
that the justice of god is indeed just that's what
we'll be doing by the way it may be a sad time for
some of us because tears will not yet be wiped
from the eyes because you may have to examine the
record or eye of a lost relative or a lost friend
and the person you know what's coming for that
person and you're looking at that person's case
so it'll be a trying time even up there because
sin is not yet done away with completely and so
our activities will be reigning with christ for
a thousand years and sitting with him in judgment
the investigative judgment the father is the judge
the judgment that takes place in a thousand
years christ is the judge we are his assistants
amen amen thank you thank you for that elder skeet
you know as you were talking i was just taken
aback look at the great god of the universe
wants human beings to take part in his work
yes in examining his judgment which we know
is just and we are all we can also affirm
amos 3 verse 7 which says surely the lord god
will do nothing but he revealeth his secrets
unto his servants the prophets our god will
never take a move without informing us first
you